travel
Michael the claims general manager for a
large global insurance company has
rolled out a new claims handling process
using IBM Business Process manager the
success of this BPM project drives the
adoption of IBM BPM throughout the
organization over time Adam the IT
administrator has installed separate VPN
deployments for each department so that
the infrastructure can be managed and
scaled independently some departments
even have separate environments to
isolate processes Sarah a claims handler
indicates that she needs to use a
different process portal depending on
the process that she wants to use with
BPM 8 5 7 Adam uses the process
Federation server to enable business
users to access all their processes
using a single process portal the
process Federation server AP is are
identical to those provided by the
process server so the process portal is
simply configured to use the process
Federation server instead a process
Federation server even works with
different versions of BPM and can
federate both BPMN and Pipal tasks
without Sarah needing to be aware of the
implementation or origin
has decided to upgrade from BPM 801 3 to
BPM 85 7 so that he can leverage the
latest mobile and case management
capabilities to improve his business
operations further Adam installs a new
instance of BPM 8 5 7 so that new
processes can be rolled out without
having to migrate the existing processes
first
the original processes are also deployed
to BPM 857 so that any new instances are
started on the new environment once all
instances on BPM 801 three environments
have completed then it can be
decommissioned
over the lifetime of the claims process
Adam timescale the process server in
line with business growth with process
Federation server Adam can now scale the
beef in infrastructure further by adding
more process servers as required
is very pleased that they've decided to
move to BPM 857 so that he can isolate
processes manage departmental
deployments massively scaled the BPM
infrastructure managed my gracious and
combine different task implementations
without impacting business operations
[Music]